Hello there, and welcome
to this piece of internet.
So why did I pour some beer
out and put water in it,
I don't understand.
We're gonna do a little test,
a test where you take a bottle of beer
then get rid of the
beer, then put water in.
And then you give it a
right whack on the top.
A right whack?
Yeah.
Doesn't it just make the
beer fizz out everywhere,
is that what you mean?
If it's beer it does.
What does water do?
Well water, what will happen is,
the water will lift from the bottom,
'cause of the downward force,
creating a little vacuum cavitation
and then when the water catches up
and slams back down, it'll blow
out the bottom of the glass.
Do you think?
Yeah.
How hard do you have to hit the bottle?
Pretty hard.
Sounds interesting.
See if it works.
What, now?
Yeah.
Really, with my hand?
It's not gonna work with my hand.
Yeah it will.
No it won't.
Go on, try it.
No.
Why?
It's just gonna fall out of my hand.
Well hold it, hold onto it.
Never before known that, that works.
Course it works.
I gave it a right whack.
Look, you see this, science.
Were you really not
expecting that to work?
No.
I wonder if we'll be able to see
your mind being blown, live on camera.
We will.
All right, we're filming this
at 2500 frames a second, which
is a hundred times slower.
Hopefully we'll see the bubbles or vacuum,
in the bottom of the beer bottle.
Are we good?
Let me just frame it, okay, give it some.
Ready?
Yeah, whack the hell out of it.
Smacked that.
All right, well I think that was
some pretty top cavitation right there.
Wasn't bad, you could
probably win some bets
at a bar with something
like that, couldn't you?
Yeah.
I can smash a bottle with just my hands.
Yeah and you'd do it to impress a girl,
you smash the bottle and then she goes,
what're you doing, you
idiot, you just broke beer
all over the pub, get out.
I thought they'd say, oh,
do you wanna come back to
mine, that was amazing.
Maybe girls treat us differently,
I think that's what it is.
Oh, funny that, sorry.
All right, how's it going?
Yeah I've been doing pretty
well, thanks for asking.
This video was brought
to you by Audible.com
and if you sign up using
the link Audible.com/slowmo,
you will get a free
audio book, pretty good.
There's actually over 100,000 of them,
that you can choose from.
This time, I'm gonna recommend
the Steve Jobs biography.
Because, I'm actually honestly,
still pretty sad that he's
dead, interesting fellow.
Also you should subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys,
because, you know, you wanna know
when a new slow mo comes out, right?
Right, good, click subscribe.